The earliest
humans didn't have words for colors.
They had words for objects and actions.
And it took tens of thousands of years
for those words
to evolve into the names of the colors
we use today.
Looking back, gives us a glimpse
at how those early people saw
the world around them.
We'll also answer that age old question:
which came first?
Orange the fruit, or orange the color?
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky
and this is Otherwords.
The human eye
can perceive millions
of slight gradations of color.
But unless you're a designer or an artist,
you probably
only regularly use
about ten or so color words.
And they are remarkably similar across
all cultures.
A landmark study by Brent Berlin and Paul
Kay found that people across the world
developed their words for colors in more
or less the same chronological order.
For example,
if a language only had two words for
colors, they were always black and white.
If a language had only three color words,
they were black, white and red.
Yellow and green came next in either
order, then blue, brown and so on.
This hierarchy closely matches
human psychology.
After all,
what could be more visually fundamental
than the dichotomy
between light and darkness?
And we're hardwired to have
a strong emotional reaction to red,
as it has a lot of survival significance
from food to sex to violence.
Blue is surprisingly far
down the list, considering it's
most people's favorite color.
But actually due to a chemical quirk,
blue is very rare in nature, except,
of course, for the sky.
But you don't really need a word
to help identify the sky.
Which sky do you mean?
Oh, the blue sky!
The English word white
can be traced all the way back
to the Proto-Indo-European root kweit
Which meant to shine.
Black similarly goes back to the P.I.E. bhleg,
which meant to burn, a reference
to the color of what's left after burning
red is unique in that it's
the only color that has a P.I.E. root
that just meant the same thing: red.
Although it may have been used to describe
anything that had a warm or interesting color.
Yellow came from the P.I.E. ghel,
which also meant to shine
and gave us many related words
like gold, glimmer, glow and gleam.
Green comes from the P.I.E. ghre,
which meant to grow
for its obvious connection to plants
and also gave us graze and grass.
Interestingly, even though humans
can perceive more shades of green
than any other color,
we just use one word for them all.
Think about it.
How many different kinds of red
can you name compared to different kinds
of green?
The reason is probably
that even though our ancestors
were surrounded by green, or rather
because they were surrounded by green,
it's just not that interesting to us.
A 2016 study by Hannah J. Haynie
and Claire Bowern found that humans
across many different languages
have an easier time communicating
warm colors than cool colors.
This color wheel, for instance,
has twice as many common color
words on the warm side than the cool side.
To understand why,
just picture with the world
may have looked like to our early ancestors.
Which things in their field of view
were worth talking about?
The cool colored ones
or the warm colored ones?
Perhaps for this reason,
the word blue has been traced
back to the P.I.E. root bhle,
which meant yellow.
There simply wasn't a need to describe
the color blue until much later on
when humans started making dyes and paints
from rare materials like lapis lazuli.
Orange was pretty late to the scene.
The old English term for the color
between yellow and red
was geoluhread,
which literally meant yellow-red.
But then sometime around the 15th
or 16th century, Portuguese merchants
began importing an exotic fruit to Europe,
known by its Sanskrit name, naranga.
This came to be known naranja in Spanish,
arancia in Italian, and orange in French.
The latter two likely dropped
the N at the beginning through confusion
about where the article ended.
It's the same way we got an apron from
a napron and a nickname from an eke name.
Over the next couple hundred years,
people went from saying things were orange
colored or the color of an orange
to just saying they were orange.
So there you have it.
The fruit came first.
But we're still living with the effects
of not having a proper name
for the color for a long time.
It's why this is called a redhead
and this a red robin,
even though they're both clearly the color
of an orange.
Brown comes from the P.I.E. bher, which meant bright,
possibly in the sense of polished wood.
Indeed, it also gives us the word
burnished.
The animal
that we today call a bear went by a
totally different word
prior to the Middle Ages.
But since it was considered dangerous to
even mention the fearsome beast by name,
ancient hunters came up with the euphemism:
bero, which meant brown one.
They were so superstitious, in fact,
that the true old English word for bear
is now lost to history.
Purple is one of the few common
color words without a root.
It comes from the Latin purpura,
which referred to a certain shellfish
that was ground down to make
a distinctly colored dye.
Because of its vibrance and rarity,
Purple became very popular
with the wealthy and powerful and
is still associated with royalty today.
It wasn't really until humans
became proficient artists
that we started adding colors
to our vocabulary by the hundreds.
Most are either based on the source
of the pigment, like stones, plants
and insects,
or to what the color reminds us of,
whether it's the sky,
the birds or a beverage.
So how many unique color names are there?
It's hard to say, but it's definitely
in the hundreds, if not thousands.
Some have long histories dating back
to the beginning of civilization,
and some were made up recently
by crayon marketing departments.
You may not need more than ten or
so on a day to day basis,
but the explosion of words shows
that color has gone from something
that we just used to survive
to an integral part
of expressing ourselves
and making our imaginations a reality.
What could
be more visually fundamental than the--
Then the dichotomy...
considering it's
most people's favorite color.